um let's do um um cardi b interviewing
joe biden
her name is barbara walters all right
barbara walters walters
the b stands for barbara walters barbara
welter she interviewed the former vice
president of the united states
and current presidential nominee and
then the next day
she went and made a personal video a
news video
so imagine imagine barbara walter
sitting down and interviewing
you know any of the former presidents in
the 90s or even even interviewing uh
barack obama and then her
next instagram post should be this
ph balance is off and you wanna know why
it's not because you're born with it
it's because i keep [ __ ] these dirty
ass [ __ ] and y'all [ __ ] are shy to
tell these [ __ ] that they dick is hot
you gotta tell babe yo your dick smell
like mustard my [ __ ] you wanna throw my
ph balance off yeah [ __ ] be [ __ ]
these little dirty ass [ __ ] gotta be
sucking they dick and [ __ ]
y'all be gagging on it y'all think y'all
gagging on it cause the dick is big
but no [ __ ] it's because it's stink
another thing is right while your phone
i got an issue with her interviewing the
president potential of the united states
he shouldn't even know who cardi b
is we should not be living in a country
it's a full-on carnival now
right where she's going hold up hold up
hold up these [ __ ]
i'm telling you you'll be putting these
stank dicks in your [ __ ] hold up hold
up
hold up i gotta just i gotta talk to
butchers butchers golly for a second
because i'm interviewing the former
secretary general of the united nations
tomorrow
okay boutrow's tomorrow 12th okay anyway
your [ __ ] is dry [ __ ]
yeah i i gotta be honest with you it's
horrifying but it's just if you just let
go
it's a fun america i mean we're just
cardi b's interview with joey b
i got a whitney eastern t-shirt on kanye
west is writing for president i mean
the truth is it's all let we've let go
now and it's all crumbling and i
like it yeah it's kind of like we've let
go it's we have let go you know our
country's like uh
a country's like a guy who was on a diet
who tried really hard to stay in shape
and then he just said [ __ ] it yeah
started eating ben and jerry's every day
then we got anderson cooper
uh flipping out on the my pillow ceo why
is the my pillow ceo even on anderson
cooper's show
you know what i wish the [ __ ] my
pillow guy would go over there and
[ __ ] smother you to death but it's my
pillow yeah cause supposedly the uh
my pillow guy get him off your show
anderson yeah
ceo michael and dell of the my pillow
which by the way my pillow's one of the
most uncomfortable [ __ ] pillows
i've ever put my head on but it was made
in america so support the troops or
whatever
yeah that's the marketing ploy but
anyway he had some uh he he had some
potential
therapeutic remedy for covet 19 and of
course
of course that means he should have an
invitation up to talk to anderson cooper
it's what it is some [ __ ] crazy guy
who sells pillows on tv
so let's put him on mainstream let's
hear this video mikey i want to hear i
want to hear what the my pillow guy has
to say
i mean yeah are they gonna have the
shamwow guy on next
[Laughter]
what if yeah yeah let's hear what the
shamwows guys opinions on
what we should do with the uh middle
east peace agreement yeah i mean and
i mean it's just there's too much what
you said what you there's too much news
and what you said the other day is if
you're getting paid like this to have an
opinion then you can't really be trusted
and that goes the same for us but go
ahead and go go to manscape.com yeah but
we're not paid to tell the truth we're
paid to farm the microphone's a dude
go to hawthorne.com that's
i meant to say because the [ __ ] m is
stupid i don't care
okay this the product smells good it
really does smell good it's for your
skin use the promo code wild
hawthorne.co um hawthornewithanee.com go
get your skin cream
and your soaps and your subs and your
colognes
yeah be a man it's a good gift it's a
good gift for your birthday or a
father's day gift even though
they was three months ago it doesn't
matter christmas gift who knows there
probably won't be answers
[Music]
you could be in the old west standing on
a box telling people to drink your
amazing
i do what jesus has me do i give the
glory to god and i want to help people
that's my passion i'm not driven
i'm not money true remedies that are not
remedies
why would i do this anderson do you and
[ __ ] andy cohen have the [ __ ]
answer
is that what you're trying to tell me do
you and andy cohen know what's going on
shut up yes my pillow guy knows the
truth he's getting my vote
yeah you know china has said that the
democratic protesters will never win
they've got a stranglehold nine taiwan
there's a middle middle east peace
agreement there's things going on in
south america in our country things are
on fire but you know what anderson
cooper
took time out of a very uh you know
skinny
news day to talk to the my pillows yeah
i don't ever want to see anderson cooper
anybody from cnn ever bitching at the
president for playing golf
during a pandemic or bitching about
anything when you
are wasting time with the my pillow guys
so shut the [ __ ] up and take your shirt
off i've been saying that for a long
time anderson because you always give us
glimpses of it
on your instagram but you need to
[ __ ] put that camera down a little
bit i'm ready to jerk off yeah
shut the [ __ ] up and take your shirt off
and thank you oh my god anderson
thank you for exposing that the guy that
sells a brick
as a pillow and says it's made in
america is a snake oil salesman we
didn't know
we couldn't tell thank you for being
such a muckraker
you descendant of billionaires yeah [ __ ]
you
go make sure you rate review us
subscribe
uh turn on your notifications get jiggy
with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild
[Music]